long walk on a cold day
I've learned about injuries is listen to
your body if your body's hurting it's
trying to tell you something in this
case right here this leg is trying to
tell me not to use it it's good take it
easy take it one step at a time
eventually I'll get back even if I get
back slowly it's good to be home get
inside take my clothes off get some rest
Hertz so you can just take my boot off
not if you can't walk on snowshoes you
basically can't walk out here at this
time here you can't get around oh yeah
it's definitely swollen right in this
area I think I'm having a problem with
the tendons that they became inflamed
because of overuse I was snowshoeing so
much so I'm gonna try heat and cold I
don't get injured very often but when I
have a problem like this I have to take
care of it myself I can't make a trip to
the doctor's office cuz it's 200 miles
down the Fairbanks cost a few thousand
dollars to go there just give it time
and have patience your body will heal
itself eventually of most things that
happened to you that's all I can do is
just wait treat it as best I can and see
what happens